[Music]
disgusting shame you can't do it
where the hell am I Donald Donald God
are you there
It's Me Margaret
whoa who the hell are you and what did
you do with Margaret
there is no Margaret dumbass I'm you I'm
a being that your subconscious created
to talk to your conscience why I'm your
psyche or at least the part that hasn't
given up on you yet
psyche that's a hilarious way to say I'm
kidding not no dummy psyche it's brain
I'm pretty much your last shred of
self-awareness and I am very very
disappointed in you
which means I'm disappointed in me which
is incredibly disappointing cool man
that's goal in that case my name's Mike
Pence and I'm one bad hombre so whatever
you do make sure you punish him I mean
me that's Mike Pence my CP and you're
winking into an empty boy you're an
empty void yeah that's exactly my point
hey it's me so handsome and you're a
cool unprepared ignorant liar but people
love that I'm a cruel unprepared
ignorant liar but those people are
bullies fear mongers xenophobes racists
and sexist Congrats what a crowd all I
heard was sex
and congrats my point is that the worst
people love you doesn't that tell you
anything it tells me that somebody loves
me and that feels nice
it shouldn't I've got news for you pal
you are not special you are pathetic
you have intentionally written to power
on a wave of the darkest forces in
American culture because you know you
can't stand on your own intellect or
ideas your
racist bag moldy biscuit dough this
isn't fun I'm bored you don't get to be
bored you know get to be petty you don't
get to frighten our children with
nuclear holocaust just so you can look
tough you're a threat to humanity you're
a disgrace to the world shut up
get him out of here get him out of here
oh that's a great idea get you out of
here you were mentally unstable and
mentally unfit to be President
and you should be removed from office
now let me try this again I am mentally
unstable and unfit to be President and
should be removed from the office I'm
bored again that's it I'm done I'm gonna
go live in the part of your mind that's
just a video of two kangaroos boxing
okay bye-bye brain guy well I remember
any of this
no you never do wait which one of us is
Margaret
neither unfortunately we're both Donald
Donald Donald Donald Donald Donald